hi everyone my name is Raj ad robit I'm
a product
here at Google Play welcome to plate
for being here today I'd like to
actually introduce both mark and Jim
before we go ahead and get started so
mark if you can go ahead and introduce
yourself and we'll go from there
hi everyone I'm mark Piniella I'm the
senior director of business development
at Kabam
and I lead a platform partnership
strategy and operations and I'm Jim
Stern general manager of the casual
cards division at Zynga working on
global games like solitaire and gin
rummy Plus that have an emergence or
presence in the emerging market as well
as some games that are just in the
emerging markets thank you both for
being here today we we're really happy
to have you guys up here so in order to
set up the the discussion the panel for
today I wanted to just talk about what
we mean when we talk about emerging
markets now given the audience given the
context when we say emerging markets up
here we're talking really any
non-western non-us market so essentially
the rest of the world there's a lot of
economic definitions for that and you
might have users in particular countries
but really what we mean is any user
that's not US UK Canada the other thing
to call out too is when we were actually
sitting here and talking with our team
about how we want to structure this
session we wanted to talk more about how
you can find success in emerging markets
I think it would be a little bit
disingenuous for us to come up here and
talk about how to approach an emerging
market because many of you already have
users that are there and you're either
deciding how to react to them at this
moment or how to potentially drive more
business from them now given all of that
we have three different things that
we're gonna be talking about three
different topics that we're gonna focus
on the first being pricing and
monetization so how do you price your
goods and services to these users what
are some strategies or some challenges
that come with that the second one is
around localization so not just
translating your app of your game but
being culturally relevant being
culturally aware of your users and then
the third one is the technical
challenges what do you what do you have
to overcome from a technical perspective
in order to launch in a particular
market so starting off with pricing and
monetization mark I'd like to actually
calling you in terms of the work that
you guys have done in terms of pricing
give us a sense for some of the
challenges you guys faced when it comes
to how you sell your goods how you sell
your games to users in those markets
what were some ideas that you guys
started off with and then what were some
solutions that you went forward with yes
sir so could be I'm active and like we
pride ourselves on a really robust live
ops program and strategy and including
that as like a lot of a lot of different
strategies that we try to implement
especially with pricing pricing
sensitivity analysis and testing for
example for India and for Brazil
not only do we have like our standard
global pricing on our pay wall but we
actually put low price entry points I ap
and three points that's a little bit
more affordable for those those markets
we did see like a uplift in that
purchase velocity for those lower price
ie PS but we we thought we could do more
so we reached out to Google Play to see
whether or not they could help us get
more best practice information for India
and Brazil so we met with Daniel at in
the Brazil team and he actually
mentioned that our pricing strategy in
in the Brazil market is it's pretty
appropriate then we taught to Kahn on in
the India in Google India team and she
mentioned that we're we're still a
little bit too we're too expensive for
that region so what we did is instead of
putting a $97 pricing USD pricing
equivalent in India we did something a
little bit lower we did a 10 rupee offer
which equates to around like 15 cents
USD and while it was price really low we
did make it up in volume 2 so there's no
one-size-fits-all for emerging markets
but we got it we just got a test
different price points yeah for sure and
Jim with you guys as well when with some
of the markets you're approaching how do
you think about that yeah also let's
kind of take a look at it from a
different perspective which is just
taking a look at what the cultural and
worldwide events are that are going on
that you have to be aware of so for
example with our games in Turkey
there's Ramadan and Eid which is very
important and so we want to make sure
that we want to encourage the gameplay
during that time period so we'll put
special sales on during that
time period but won't run any special
you way campaigns because we know we
want that get that kind of return during
that time period and then other things
like that tax you know at the beginning
of the year we started charging fat on
top of all of the packages that we had
and we had to be really aware of what
the impact of that was going to be on
the players especially on the lower end
the entry points because on the google
site at least there's no pricing tiers
so we can actually set up whatever we
need to and on the other side there are
so we have to figure out what kinds of
items we want to put in there that will
entice them more or how we even pop up
those messages to get some of those
early players on board and then I said
finally one other a global perspective
it's even taking a look at the the local
currency so in the case of Turkey where
we've got a big presence you know over
the this last year that there's been a
huge devaluation in the market and when
you need to take a look out there then
is how do you make sure that you're
being sensitive to what's going on there
did you put on sales do you actually
reprice what you're doing at that time
or do you try to come up with
alternative packages like rewarded
videos where they don't have to spend as
much during the time where the the lira
is a lot lower and really make sure that
they're able to still continue to play
so I want to actually follow up on that
too so this is this is interesting
you're having to think about like
geopolitical happening around the world
to understand like currency devaluation
what did you guys decide to do in that
moment did you did you move with
rewarded video did you change the
pricing like how did how did you
actually react to that no so what we
figured was it was really important to
watch what was going on in the market
and because these are a lower pricepoint
entry it doesn't really impact that part
of the business as much so we decided to
wait and see what would happen and
things actually turned out fine in terms
of what players were interested in and
being able to engage in the the game and
it's the one piece that I think is
really important don't react quickly and
don't say okay I'm gonna repress
everything right away sit wait see
what's gonna happen and make sure that
you're really listening to what
players want that's great and Mark I
wanted to actually touch on something
you were talking about previously you
know we gave you guys advice around what
kind of pricing makes sense in
particular markets have you done any
testing beyond that in terms of maybe
even adjusting up or below what we we
talked about previously or has there
been like any sort of hey be testing
that you guys have done with that yeah
me we a be test everything you know but
outside of pricing we actually do
because like we create the Marvel
contest of Champions game we know what
characters kind of resonate in certain
markets as well so we actually do when
we look at our offers that we do in
those different markets we actually look
at which characters in which packages
makes more sense for that region so we
do outside of price and we do tailor it
culturally to for the for the market
that's actually so taking that
discussion now I'd actually like to
transition to this idea of localization
so probably about six years ago or five
years ago I would have just told you to
translate your app and then call it a
day that's completely changed right it's
not just about you know translating to
Spanish or Mandarin or Portuguese it's
about you know running sales during need
or doing something specific to those
particular markets Jim let's talk about
some of the work you guys did with with
okie and Turkey understanding sort of
how you guys how you guys first
approached that market thought about you
know the way you wanted to set up the
game and then some of the things that
you did in terms of actually delivering
content to users there it be great to
just walk through all that okay yeah
that's okay is a tile-based
gin game similar to rummy cube and it's
very popular it's very traditional in
their card houses there so people have
been playing it for years and they play
socially they play for money there's a
lot that goes on around that as a
community so we figured let's tap into
something that actually resonates with
that community there eighty million or
so people in Turkey and there's a large
portion that actually play the game as
well so our first important thing to do
is make sure that we had a synchronous
game play and just set it up that way
how do you make it so that people can
get on to
players three players four players on
top of that we then added community and
customer service and with the customer
service is important to have people who
were from Turkey not only had to speak
the language I could say and don't worry
about necessarily Justin's translation
but really understood the mentality of
people who play the game and what
they're looking for and then we finally
added a component on top of that where
they could wager for chips and really
get that additional excitement around it
and what was important I think for
throughout this whole thing was the
timing the the patient of the game what
the tiles look like even your avatar in
can phrases that weren't just translated
through some app but things that were
typically known within that particular
culture yeah we there was one partner we
were talking to before the panel and she
was mentioning how they leveraged their
community inside the app so they have a
very strong passionate user base that
actually just volunteered their time
they they were given a space in terms of
becoming like a brand ambassador an app
ambassador for them and they they
actually reach out to these users in
particular markets as the individual
that represents that country it makes
the user feel extremely happy to be have
that honor especially if they love the
service or they love the app but they
essentially become like a sounding board
for any any changes that can happen in
that local market so much like what we
did with Daniel and Kannan in India and
in Brazil they sort of act as like the
individual that you can reach out to and
say hey we're trying to get this message
across does this make sense is this the
right messaging that we want to say and
in many times they'll actually come back
and say no you mean to say this instead
yeah so it's a good check on a lot of
the work that they're doing in terms of
approaching those markets and it's
ideally somewhat lightweight in terms of
leveraging those resources leveraging
your users to actually get that
information but mark however you guys
thought about cultural culturalization
localization for your offerings so um
there's something interesting that we do
like we can be on like a we actually
have really deep roots with like with UC
Berkeley and what we've been doing like
all of our founders came from Cal and
what we did with them was we partnered
with the hospice school to do a research
competition to see which markets outside
of the tier one
have the highest growth potential and
there's a bigger opportunity there so
it's no surprise that both India and
Brazil as well as like Southeast Asia
came up in the in the research so right
now we're actually moving to phase 2 and
phase 2 actually we're gonna be
partnering with the university in India
to go a little bit more deeper on not
only just like the game market over
there but also the game tech and the
flavor profile and with the reason why
we're doing that with the university in
India is because we identified them as a
growth market and in the emerging market
those people are on the ground there so
that's why we wanted to do that so
that's how we're kind of learning from
the folks over there on the ground
interesting is is I don't know if you
can say this is like a financial
relationship or is it just purely
research or how does it your research I
mean we're partnering with the
universities were giving them there's a
price where ever wins you know so just
helps where the tuition so okay that's
great yeah yeah so I mean I think that
there's a lot of these different things
to think about when you're obviously
trying to sell your specific service to
these markets
I'd like to potentially now transition
to some of these technical issues that a
lot of our partners face and actually
you know we were talking previously the
panel that even size can be a big issue
so Jim walk us through some of the the
technical things that you had to think
about before you approach the market or
also just technical issues that you
might have encountered before you after
you entered that we were surprised about
later
right you were surprised about it how
did you react to them how did you guys
build in flex to me be able to address
those issues for your users as well so
we had a couple of different things
going on with a few of our games so in
the case of okay that I was talking
about it's predominantly played in
Turkey and the closest AWS server that
we could get was in Germany so there
were some latency issues not horrible
but we were able to find servers that
were local within Turkey that were price
competitive as well that actually were
much better in terms of the latency
issue so we were able to hook them up
over there we've also had
situations like with poker will we
thought okay this is a global game how
do we target the particularly merchant
markets let's segment the servers based
off of the different languages of the
different countries with the people
they're playing and we found that
actually had an issue on liquidity that
people weren't able to find other
players because there were on different
servers so to accommodate for that we
put everybody back into a single set of
servers again and in order to customize
the game for them we try to give them
customized events that we were
customized from that particular culture
but then make something else that was a
little bit more generic for the rest of
the world and then in the case of
rangoli rekha which is a match-three
game that we did in india it was very
important that we knew the customer base
so it's predominantly Android so we
focused on Android
they don't have the same access to Wi-Fi
so we had to make sure that the file
size was down so we kept in to 20 Meg's
and based on the research that we had
done we found that it's up to 40% of the
people find other file share servers to
go to to download the game so we made
sure it was accessible through you know
services like fire share in order to be
for them to be able to download their
games now mark did you guys have any
similar issues around size or anything
like that or is that a consideration for
you guys it's definitely a huge
consideration so four years ago when
Marvel contest of Champions launched we
like players actually had to be on Wi-Fi
in order to download the game the game
is huge
I would say like on device around like
700 megabytes so you could see that
could be a hurdle for acquisition so we
like shortly after that we had to
quickly pivot our central tech strategy
so what we did is that we made our
initial download 700 megabytes and what
that did for us has enabled players to
download the game over cellular and
while they're playing through the
tutorial our game leverages on-demand
resources to download the rest of the
package so not only did we see like
optimization and our yields and our CPI
is but also
made our game more accessible in the
emerging markets where the
infrastructure wasn't really fully
developed and Wi-Fi wasn't really
available yeah and I mean I think that
highlights a lot of what we were talking
about earlier today when you saw dom up
here on stage why we're so focused on
size reduction you can see the benefits
around actually taking this type of
model you know more modular approach
more dynamically loading content and
that's really why we we built the bundle
that's why we built that technology and
I can't reiterate that enough I think
we've seen a lot of partners report to
us how how important that's been for
their business I mean just something so
simple as size reduction can really
Drive that now we're there were there
any technical challenges that you had to
overcome through that size reduction or
through that kind of like dynamically
loading information that you know maybe
you could share some details on in terms
of actual tech yeah so I'm not an
engineer I really can't tell you like
all the details but it was definitely
not an easy process that was it I think
the time that we said we need to do this
versus like when we actually executed
was a good like six months so I would
say if you guys are starting it if
you're starting off from a full package
download to to actually changing your
strategy and doing like an initial
download take some time to think through
it
yeah and that's so that's a good thing
to call out to I think when we have
these conversations with our partners a
lot of times it's not just a quick
change that you can put into place this
is really an architecture decision at
the end of the day and that can you kind
of have to leverage a lot of resources
to make that happen so that that kind of
definitely lines up with a lot of things
that we're talking to partners about but
I'd like to maybe just take a take stock
of a lot of these ideas and if you could
maybe talk about one or two things that
you'd want the audience to take away
from something that you know we can
hopefully take away as an actionable
item that they can test back home with
with some of their colleagues Jim maybe
we'll start with you what are what are
some a few things that you can talk
about that if you're trying to
prioritize these items and these these
tasks what are things that they can do
to try and you know find success in
these markets might say first and
foremost if you're looking to do it
or an application in the particular
market make sure you've really done your
research to know what are the traditions
there what do people glom on to why did
they do it the more you can actually
have it built there as well whether
people know the the traditions they know
the culture it's much better because
even the subtleties that they put into
the game or and make an incredible
difference seem like I was talking about
before customer service have it there
they'll understand that you know how to
talk with the people there how to
communicate with them
and I wouldn't just second that I guess
to creating an app for a particular
market but if you have a larger app that
is global how do you tap into those
emerging markets and in some cases it is
customizing events or sales or whatever
it is that you want to put out to them
it will cost a little bit more it'll
take more time to put together but they
value that and they really enjoy seeing
that they're an important piece to
what's going on you can also get into
those emerging markets if you're
worldwide because like I was talking
about the liquidity there may be these
smaller countries where you don't have a
it's it's not profitable enough for you
to build something just for that but you
can tap into it by leveraging all the
rest of the other people so don't just
ignore emerging markets because you
don't think you can get into it leverage
everything else that you're doing in
terms of rest of world yeah mark I think
if you could give us maybe a few things
to think about as well yeah I mean like
from a pricing perspective I would just
say av-test
everything I mean sometimes like the the
biggest wins and learnings come out of
trial and error but I guess like my my
more general takeaway and advice I could
give is to don't be afraid to ask for
help and leverage your external
resources whether it's Google Play or
local universities or even like your
peers in the industry chances are they
know something you learn something about
member gmarks that you didn't know and
the advice is free - awesome well thank
you both for for being up here today you
know super helpful and we
I appreciate you guys sharing this
detail and actually one more thing I
wanted to call out too so there's a new
feature that we had talked about earlier
that's launching on the play console
which is called country targeting so for
those of you who've used locale
targeting previously you might have had
some issues where users for example in
India you know they set their phones to
English us and so you're not necessarily
able to actually deliver content that's
specific to a particular market but we
currently have that in an early access
program and so I'd love for everyone to
take a look if you go to go a G Co /
play / country targeting again that URL
is G Co a / play / country targeting
thank you both thank you
[Applause]